l'accident de seveso inquiète et pays
européens déjà la commission de la cea
mise à la disposition des autorités
italiennes
une aide technique mais des médecins
ouest allemand accuse le gouvernement
italien d'avoir minimisé la plus grande
catastrophe par gaz du monde pour eux la
région de seveso devrait être interdite
pendant 15 ans enfin monsieur jacques
chirac lui aussi se préoccupe des
conséquences de cet accident il va se
renseigner et si l'on fabrique en france
du triple euros fait nole ce gaz qui
entre dans la composition du gaz
toxiques
eh bien il se propose d'en interdire la
fabrication sage précaution
mais dans l'hypothèse d'un accident
semblable en france pourrait tomber ou
non guérir les personnes intoxiquées
docteur dali cette petite fille est
l'une des victimes de la dioxine
quelles sont ses marques je pense qu'il
s'est effectivement des lésions de
dermatites aiguë tel qu'on en est décrit
avec le dioxyde en particulier chez des
ouvriers qui étaient employés à la
fabrication d re me sidère qui comptait
ce produit tout provient généralement la
dioxine
alors la dioxine est une impureté de
fabrication qui apparaît au cours de la
synthèse d'herbicides et en particulier
du 2 4 5t qui est un produit utilisé
pour débroussailler des formes et dans
l'état actuel des conditions de
fabrication les herbicides y at il en
france par exemple des dangers possibles
dans les conditions normales de
fabrication non parce que c'est un
problème qui en fait n'est pas récent
pour les
les spécialistes et actuellement il ya
des normes de fabrication qui sont
extrêmement sévères
aucun herbicide contenant plus d'une
partie pour 10 millions c'est à dire
l'identité extrêmement un fils ne peut
normalement être mise dans le commerce
est ce qu'on connaît les conséquences de
telle est ma nation venu aux-in alors
chez l'animal y ait des travaux assez
nombreux qui ont été faits on sait que
c'est un produit qui est cancérigène
pour l'homme et pour l'animal qui
provoque en particulier des tumeurs du
foie
on sait que c'est un produit qui était
rathjen qui provoque des anomalies de la
face chez les nouveau-nés et
probablement si des anomalies des reins
par contre chez l'homme évidemment les
travaux sont bien avancés la seule
référence que l'on est
c'est ce qui s'est passé au vietnam les
médecins vietnamiens disque à la suite
des faits du répondant macif qui a été
fait par les américains la fréquence des
cancers du foie a triplé dans la
population du nord vietnam en dix ans et
maintenance et on soignait alors le
traitement actuellement il uniquement
symptomatiques on peut soigner les
conséquences de
de la dioxine peut penser qu'il ya des
recherches qui se poursuivent
actuellement pour essayer de trouver ou
un antidote moyenne de décontamination
que le rapide mais à ma connaissance il
n'y a rien dans ce domaine qui soit
actuellement disponibles immédiatement